bonsoir à tous ravi de vous retrouver
c'est ça vous regarde ce soir notre
grand témoin et bien va nous plonger au
cœur du complot c'est le titre de votre
dernier livre Rudy reichstad bonsoir
paru chez Grasset c'est un court essai
passionnant autant qu'un récit personnel
sur votre travail démontez la mécanique
des complotistes qui pullulent sur les
réseaux sociaux et pour la première fois
et bien vous raconter le torrent debout
qui s'est abattu sur vous depuis la
création de votre site conspiration
watch on va y revenir dans le détail
tout à l'heure mais on va commencer par
débattre ce soir du RSA terraminé pour
le gouvernement qui veut réformer le
revenu de solidarité active en le
conditionnant à quelques heures
d'activités chiffon rouge pour la gauche
qui fustige la stigmatisation des
précaires et insuffisant pour la droite
qui dénonce l'assistanat alors peut-on
faire du RSA le moyen de retrouver un
travail grand débat avec mes invités
dans un tout petit instant sur ce
plateau avant de retrouver bien sûr
nos affranchis pour leur parti pris et
puis bon Express l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée voilà pour le menu ce soir
vous me suivez rue des rastaï et bien ça
vous regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
trois lettres trois lettres qui laissent
présager une réforme très compliquée
pour l'exécutif RSA pour revenus de
solidarité active le gouvernement avance
sur la pointe des pieds pour que ce RSA
ne soit plus versé automatiquement sans
contrepartie mais commencer par ce texte
pour renouer le dialogue est-ce bien
raisonnable Loïc senior bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes porte-parole
de renaissance le parti présidentiel et
vous débattez ce soir avec Aurélie
trouvée bienvenue et merci d'être là
député la France insoumise de
Seine-Saint-Denis le département de la
Seine-Saint-Denis je le précise d'entrer
de jeu qui a refusé de participer à
l'expérimentation de ce RSA sous
conditions on y reviendra bonsoir à
Benoît Reboul Salz et bienvenue sur ce
plateau vous êtes délégué national
d'adéter car monde et bonsoir Jean-Rémy
Baudot ravi de vous retrouver
journaliste politique à France Info et
chroniqueurs réguliers dans cette
émission rue des Reichstadt c'est pas
vos sujets je le sais mais le citoyen
que vous êtes a forcément un petit avis
ou même des questions à poser à nos à
nos invités on va commencer par planter
le décor RSA que compte faire
précisément le gouvernement il a 200
secondes pour faire le tour de la
question c'est le chrono de la coupe
pour démarrer
et je me retourne comme chaque soir pour
vous accueillir ces fans bonsoir bonsoir
à toutes et tous Stéphane blackovski que
veut faire le gouvernement vous nous
l'avez rappelez RSA c'est un sigle qui
signifie revenu de solidarité active
alors les deux premières lettres revenu
de solidarité c'est parce que c'est ça
on dit souvent et le dernier filet de
sécurité
plusieurs fois c'est mon problème ce
soir le RSA et le dernier donc filet de
sécurité pour les Français les plus
démunis pour fixer à gros trait les
idées voyez en France le seuil de
pauvreté pour une personne seule et
fictée à 1102 euros et bien quand on
touche un
RSA plein c'est 607 euros donc les gens
qui sont bénéficiés à locataire du RSA
sont vraiment dans une grande pauvreté
mais le débat ne se porte pas vraiment
sur les deux premières lettres RS c'est
plutôt sur la troisième lettre le a
comme active car en fait les
allocataires sont censés signer un
contrat où il s'engage à s'activer pour
le coup pour retrouver un emploi or il
est apparu que en près de 60% des
allocataires du RSA ne signe pas ce
contrat et que donc par conséquent ça
pose ce problème ça c'est une un tabou
qui vient de la Cour des comptes qui a
étudié le sujet ils ont suivi des gens
au RSA pendant 7 ans et on voit qu'au
bout de 7 ans et bien 42% sont toujours
restés au RSA donc qui peut se féliciter
que quatre allocataires sur 10 soit
toujours au RSA après je pose la
question c'est le ministre qui répond
je pense que personne ne peut se
féliciter le fait que quatre
allocataires sur 10 sont encore un
locataire du RSA cet homme après bah oui
personne peut se féliciter à moins de
relancer le débat sur le droit à la page
donc on a compris que la volonté de du
ministre c'est d'améliorer
l'accompagnement des bénéficiaires du
RSA dans l'idée qu'il retrouve du
travail donc quand on parle de 15 à 20h
d'activité quand on écoute le ministre
c'est pas des petits boulots gras donc
on va leur donner pour s'occuper mais
plutôt des heures d'activité on va les
obliger malgré tout à participer à des
formations utiles donc on a fait des
listes de quelles étaient les principaux
freins au retour à l'emploi c'est
l'adresse statistique de
l'administration qui s'en est occupé et
on se rend compte que parmi les premiers
choix donc ça c'est pas du tout
il y a donc le manque de mobilité
problème de santé donc l'idée ça serait
que des organes d'activité soit par
exemple la première ministre j'ai passé
le permis si on a l'occasion les
problèmes de santé je peux régler une
question de l'addiction avoir une carte
Vitale donc voilà à quoi sont censés
servir ces heures d'activité donc
résultat lui il nous dit carrément mais
écoutez le RSA sans condition moi je
vous dis que c'est une mesure de gauche
bon forcément à gauche on est pas tout à
fait sur la même ligne on pense pas que
c'est une mesure de gauche le RSA soit
condition au contraire le groupe
parlementaire François soumise parlait
de chasse au pauvre et vous le savez
côté du pain on est divisé sur pas mal
de choses et notamment sur ce sujet
puisque Fabien Roussel lui serait plutôt
sur la ligne de Livier du soft il trouve
que le RSA ne remplit pas son office
sans l'écoute je rencontre tant de gens
dans ma circonscription justement mais
même dans mon tour de France que j'ai
fait abîmé par le chômage bousiller par
des années à survivre au RSA ce revenu
minimum mis en place pour soi-disant
lutter contre la pauvreté mais qui en
fait installe la pauvreté dans notre
pays
bon alors évidemment ça nous rappelle un
peu c'est le polémique du début de
l'année à la fête de l'humain ou Fabien
Roussel défendait la bouche du travail
contre la gauche des allocs avec une
polémique je vous rappelle que du côté
des insoumis on avait trouvé que c'était
quand même vaguement de droite cette
réflexion et du côté des écolos on
trouvait ça un peu réactionnel alors
est-ce que le RSA sous conditions est-ce
que c'est de droite ou est-ce que c'est
de gauche vous allez pouvoir en débattre
juste un chiffre à vous montrer avant de
vous laisser les battre quand on pose la
question aux Français voyez regardez il
y a 65% d'entre eux qui trouvent qu'en
France il y a trop d'assistanats mais je
vous rappelle que c'est pas parce que
65% des Français disent un truc que
c'est vrai merci beaucoup
Stéphane le Seigneur c'est pour plaire à
ses 65% de français que vous voulez
réformer le RSA absolument pas regardez
je suis venu sans chiffre parce que je
crois que l'expérience récente de la
réforme des retraites nous a montré que
faire une bataille de chiffres ça
servait pas à grand chose faire une
bataille de cette réforme est-elle de
gauche c'est très fort mais elle de
droite ça servait pas à grand chose en
vérité je m'en fiche je veux voir que
c'est 40% de bénéficiaires de RSA qui le
sont toujours après 7 ans moi j'espère
qu'ils ne le seront plus dans 7 ans et
qu'ils auront retrouvé un travail qui
payent qui permet d'avoir une autonomie
et d'être aussi digne dans son quotidien
plutôt que recevoir cette aide de 6007
euros personne n'est riche et personne
ne souhaite que quelqu'un vive en France
avec 6007 euros en revanche que
quelqu'un est un travail le mieux payé
possible ça on le souhaite tous et je
pense de gauche comme de droite y
compris dans l'ego on vient d'entendre
Fabien Roussel je suis plutôt d'accord
avec Fabien Roussel même si je ne
poserai pas la France du travail et la
France des allocs la France est le pays
je pense qu'on peut s'engueillir de ça
qui dépensent le plus pour l'aide
sociale c'est une réalité en Europe
c'est la France on met un pognon dingue
disait certains présidents de la
République
dans des dans des circonstances comme
celle que nous avons connues avec le
covid aujourd'hui Macron lui-même au
lecteur du Parisien dit qu'il y a des
abus chez les bénéficiaires du RSA
c'est un autre sujet Gabriel Attal aura
l'occasion dans les prochains jours de
dévoiler un plan contre les fraudes mais
là aujourd'hui on parle de la
transformation de quelque chose que
personne ne veut pour son pour ses
proches sur le long terme le RSA ça doit
être une assurance ponctuelle et avec ce
contrat d'engagement réciproque c'est ce
que nous faisons alors c'est la base du
RMI à l'origine on ne réinvente pas
l'eau chaude c'est quelque chose qui
doit être mis en place tel que ça a été
premier en 1988 ça n'a jamais été
appliqué jamais respecté aujourd'hui
nous disons à ces personnes qui
bénéficient du RSA on va vous aider à en
sortir par de l'accompagnement la parole
mais vous êtes porte-parole de
renaissance vous avez des informations
que nous n'avons pas vous pouvez nous
donner des précisions sur ces heures
d'activité en contrepartie qui seront
exigés si cette réforme est votée à
l'Assemblée bien évidemment non c'est
pas moi de vous donner des précisions je
pense que c'est au Ministre en charge le
livre du socle oral occasion de les
préciser il y a 18 départements qui sont
dans une expérimentation de cette
réforme du RSA encore une fois je pense
qu'il faut des passionnés le débat
avancer avec tous les acteurs et avancer
le plus intelligemment possible encore
une fois si on fait de chaque réforme un
débat de société qui embarque les
oppositions les unes avec les autres
pour contrer simplement une réforme
présentée par Emmanuel Macron on
avancera à rien et les les grands
perdants se seront justement ces
personnes qu'on souhaite aider et
visiblement même à gauche certains
veulent aider ces personnes
on l'entend parce que de toute façon il
va falloir le trouver à l'Assemblée
nationale Aurélie trouvée en quoi c'est
c'est un problème de mieux accompagner
finalement les les bénéficiaires du rsh
ça vous choque vous c'est plutôt une
bonne idée quand on sait par vous donner
raison en effet il vaut mieux que du
côté de la minorité présidentielle vous
veniez 100 chiffres parce qu'en général
il parle contre vous et ça a été le cas
d'ailleurs pendant tout le débat contre
la réforme des retraites mais aider les
bénéficiaires à retrouver un emploi
alors je vais répondre sur le fond aussi
sur la philosophie parce que on disait
est-ce que c'est de gauche ou de droite
de avoir des conditions pour toucher un
minimum pour vivre en réalité c'est
juste la République c'est à dire qu'en
République il y a des droits
inaliénables il y a des droits garantis
protégés parce qu'on est un être humain
et c'est d'ailleurs dans la Constitution
de 1946 qui dit ceci qui dit que la
nation assure à la famille alors et à
l'individu le RSA n'est que des droits
de devoirs pour vous la possibilité de
son développement donc la liberté la
dignité ce sont des droits il a
aliénable et en fait on va de soi
Emmanuel Macron fait passer les devoirs
avant les droits et bien c'est le début
c'est le début de de la monarchie c'est
c'est le début oui c'est le début en
tout cas
monarchie là-dedans en tout cas c'est le
fait de grignoter un petit peu plus
encore l'esprit républicain et le fait
que les droits soient inaliénables ça
c'est la première chose deuxièmement
deuxièmement je remarque que ce
gouvernement sans arrêt cherche des
boucs émissaires et en l'occurrence ici
les boucs émissaires à nouveau ce sont
les chômeurs bah si c'est ce que vous
faites
permanence et par exemple vous dites
vous dites tout le temps ah bah ils
n'ont qu'à faire des efforts pour
trouver un travail je rappelle juste les
chiffres parce que ces chiffres vous
embête tu verras appeler je vous ai pas
couper monsieur je vais rappeler les
chips parce qu'il vous embêtent 5
millions de personnes inscrites à Pôle
Emploi 340 000 emplois disponibles en
2022 il y a donc 14 chômeurs pour un
emploi disponible alors vous allez
m'expliquer si vraiment c'est parce
qu'ils ne font pas assez d'efforts le
problème le problème c'est qu'il n'y a
pas assez d'emploi dans ce pays c'est la
première cause et la deuxième cause en
ce qui concerne l'accompagnement c'est
effectivement d'après les enquêtes le
transport la saint justement ou encore
le fait que ce soit des mères seuls avec
enfants qui n'ont pas entendu d'après
les informations
du ministère du Travail auraient les
trouver franchement ça pourrait
justement être une formation pour passer
le permis ça pourrait peut-être et on
attend les confirmations des ministres
mais apprendre à faire un CV faire une
demande de carte vitale Benoît reboules
sales c'est un vieux serpent de mer
cette histoire de RSA sous condition
mais de ce que vous comprenez des
volontés du gouvernement est-ce que ça
va dans le bon sens ce qui va dans le
bon sens c'est la volonté
d'accompagnement ça ça va dans le bon
sens
là où on est d'accord aussi c'est que le
RSA on est dans la survie parce que si
on découle le 607 euros en fait si on
enlève d'abord le forfait logement on
tombe à 5207 524 selon les gens et en
fin de de toute une fois toutes les
dépenses payées il reste 115 euros pour
se loger pour se vêtir pardon et se
nourrir pour tout le mois c'est
absolument impossible et tous les
allocataires du RSA que moi je rencontre
dit c'est impossible donc il y a deux
points sur nous donner un peu de vécu on
peut lire qu'un tiers de ces hommes et
femmes bénéficiaires du RSA qu'enfant à
charge on des difficultés de mobilité
parfois des problèmes de santé voire
même d'addiction
il y en a mais il y a aussi des gens
tout simplement qui
qui sont dans la pauvreté parce que ils
ont pas trouvé de travail parce que ils
ont pas pu aller à l'école ils ont pas
pu apprendre à l'école ça serait
intéressant de se poser quelle question
de qu'est-ce qui est installe la
pauvreté c'est pas simplement le manque
de revenus qui installent la pauvreté
c'est pas simplement le manque de
travail décent qui installe la pauvreté
c'est aussi l'accès au logement c'est
aussi le fait de ne pas être considéré
de ne pas avoir pu faire d'études enfin
il y a un tas de raisons et de
dimensions différentes qui sont votre
regard sur la philosophie qu'on devine
de l'exécutif au fond la contrepartie
c'est un accompagnement c'est le mot qui
est utilisé qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
alors nous on est absolument contre les
sanctions parce qu'on trouve que on est
les gens ne sont plus des enfants à qui
on dit si vous êtes sage vous aurez une
récompense le RSA si vous n'êtes pas
obéissant vous n'aurez pas de
reconnaissance
si vous ne faites pas ces heures
d'activité c'est 15 à 20h par semaine
alors on supprime voir on suspens la
situation dans un des départements qui
est qui est candidat lionne ou des gens
parce qu'ils n'ont pas répondu à un
appel masqué qui était envoyé par une
entreprise sous-traitante de Pôle Emploi
ils ont eu le RSA coupé mais quand vous
avez ce votre téléphone un appel masqué
bah forcément vous décrochez pas
forcément c'est normal et du coup on a
eu des gens coupés et évidemment ils ont
après ils ont su se défendre ils ont pu
récupérer les SMS mais c'est des mois
c'est des mois d'angoisse et comme
est-ce qu'il faut au lendemain quand
même non non c'est pas du jour au
lendemain ça prend du temps
c'est que il y a une expérimentation qui
est soi-disant en cours mais qui n'a pas
vraiment commencé on rentre à son pas
signés avec les départements et on veut
déjà la généraliser
on est allé faire un reportage justement
dans le Loiret ou ce RSA sous conditions
est expérimenté on verra quel bilan on
peut on peut rien niveau d'eau pourquoi
maintenant moi je comprends pas très
bien pourquoi ce gouvernement après une
crise des retraites aussi violente veut
faire ça alors qu'on l'entend c'est
c'est une très bonne question en réalité
le Seigneur qui pourrait peut-être y
répondre plus directement moi je
m'interroge effectivement sur la
question du timing et sur la manière
dont ces mené c'est à dire que
politiquement la manière dont le
président la première ministre on
parlait de ce sujet là à dire voilà il
faut 15 à 20h d'activités ça on entend
quelque chose de très brutal et
d'ailleurs c'est je pense c'est beaucoup
ça qui vous fait réagir et vous
néanmoins du côté de la télécommande
vous êtes plutôt à l'écoute de d'une
forme d'accompagnement et donc en fait
on est vraiment dans l'impossibilité du
débat là-dessus c'est-à-dire qu'entre
les sanctions et contre l'extension
néanmoins moi il me semble qu'il y a une
petite pierre qui manque dans l'édifice
qui est en train d'être mise en place du
côté de l'exécutif c'est la question du
budget parce que l'accompagnement il
peut fonctionner aller chercher les gens
ça peut fonctionner de les accompagner
de les sortir de vous savez en gros je
discutais hier avec un avec un un
président de de départements les
départements ce sont que ce sont eux qui
gèrent le RSA et il me disaient il y a
environ un tiers des gens RSA on est
quasiment sûr qu'on pourra quasiment
jamais les ressortir parce que c'est
trop difficile
qui sont trop éloignés de l'emploi pour
une partie des raisons qu'on a listées
tout à l'heure mais les autres en fait
on peut aller les aider le problème
c'est que dans la plupart des
départements on n'a pas forcément les
sous pour le faire et ce qui m'embête un
tout petit peu dans la démarche mise en
avant c'est que pour l'instant il n'y a
pas de budget en face de cette demande
de vous êtes un jour
et je pense d'une autre manière par
ailleurs que il y a une forme de de il y
a peut-être une problème de une
incompréhension de ce qu'est le chômage
de longue durée et de et de ce qu'est la
difficulté de se remettre dans l'emploi
quand vous êtes très éloigné de l'emploi
quand ça fait longtemps que vous êtes
sorti de la socialisation du travail que
vous n'avez plus ce cette relation avec
avec le travail c'est extrêmement
compliqué de se dire c'est vrai quand
même je vais quand même m'y remettre
honnêtement faut vraiment attendre
par la main une question quand on dit il
y a quatre personnes sur 10 qui sont RSA
7 ans après faut pas oublier qu'il y a
quatre personnes sur 10 qui ne sont pas
accompagnées au RSA aujourd'hui que le
budget du RSA pour l'accompagnement
c'est 7 % du montant accordé au RSA
c'était 20% quand le RM qui a été fondé
des choses à faire déjà maintenant qu'on
arrive à faire
on va regarder le reportage justement
sur le Loiret c'est un département dans
lequel le RSA expérimenté pourquoi déjà
c'est pour les raisons de de coup que la
Seine-Saint-Denis n'a pas voulu
bénéficier d'expérimentation évidemment
qu'on n'est pas contre la compagnon bien
entendu on pense qu'il y en a pas assez
évidemment tout ce que vous dites juste
c'est à dire que quand on a décroché en
fait du monde du travail depuis 5 ans 10
ans 15 ans il y a des raisons très
profondes qui demandent aussi des moyens
bien supplémentaires le problème la
Seine-Saint-Denis a dit non a juste
titre
voilà pour l'expérimentation parce que
ou les seuls à dire non mais tout le
monde quasiment tout le monde est
critique là-dessus ah oui pardon
l'Essonne a dit non effectivement et les
autres départements de toute façon on
l'a le même point de vue tout de même
c'est de dire il n'y a pas assez de
budget Camille en fait si vous voulez
c'est les départements qui sont
responsables aujourd'hui de la l'État ne
finance pas l'expérimentation à
100%. donc c'est des collectivités
locales déjà étranglées financièrement
qui en plus vont devoir mettre la main
quand même regarder comment ça se passe
sur le terrain direction le Loiret ou
les associations accompagnent donc de
façon individualisée les bénéficiaires
du RSA vers le retour à l'emploi c'est
signé Diane karcher
près d'Orléans Rodolphe du clou
excalocataire du RSA a été accompagnée
par le département pour revenir vers
l'emploi en échange du Revenu Minimum il
a dû assister pendant trois mois à des
ateliers et des entretiens chaque
semaine pour le confort d'avoir
quelqu'un qui
nous file un petit coup de patte pour
pour refaire un CV des fois ou même pour
avoir des contacts ce que les gens qui
m'ont accompagné avaient beaucoup de
contacts de leur métier quoi aujourd'hui
il travaille comme intérimaire dans
l'agroalimentaire comme lui en un an 70%
des participants volontaires ont
retrouvé le chemin de l'emploi
ça leur permet de sortir de chez eux de
se remettre dans une dynamique de
confiance de retrouver la confiance
aussi en les entreprises avec 17 autres
départements le Loiret est actuellement
ce qui pourrait être le futur RSA sous
conditions voulu par le gouvernement 15
à 20h de formation obligatoire par
semaine mais pour le président du
département il faudra faire preuve de
souplesse chacun doit pouvoir adapter
l'expérimentation
si c'est un cadre rigide pour moi il n'y
a pas d'expérimentation si c'est un
cadre rigide bah autant le lancer sur la
France entière tout de suite mais moi ce
que j'attends d'une expérimentation
c'est que chacun a pensé pierre
peut-être que ce qui sera en département
du Loiret ne sera pas la même chose qui
se fera dans l'Yonne ou dans la Creuse
mais les associations de lutte contre la
pauvreté alerte conditionné le RSA s'est
condamner les bénéficiaires à plus de
précarité
si la loi travail est votée le RSA sous
condition devrait être appliquée partout
en France d'ici 2027
alors Rémi Benoît pardon Benoît reboules
ça explique-nous un peu comment ça peut
se passer cet accompagnement là on
entend un bénéficiaire qui a l'air
plutôt content d'avoir bénéficié
bénéficié de cet accompagnement un peu
sur mesure c'est le département qui qui
gère qui accompagne c'est dans les
missions locales les associatives les
fonctionnaires des collectivités
l'émission locale c'est pour les jeunes
les moins de 25 ans qui ont pas accès au
RSA aujourd'hui l'accompagnement il est
fait par les travailleurs sociaux qui
dépendent du département d'accord ou
éventuellement la case d'allocations
familiales ça dépend comment c'est
organisé dans le département et
effectivement il y a des travailleurs
sociaux qui font très bien leur travail
quand on leur en donne les moyens et ce
travail c'est quoi c'est redonner
confiance pour faire un CV c'est
carrément accompagné vers le conseiller
à Pôle emploi c'est quoi précisément
l'accompagnement ça veut dire déjà
porter un regard bienveillant sur la
personne c'est déjà voir les compétences
de la personne et pas simplement ce qui
ne va pas et ça peut être plein de
choses différentes parce que la misère
elle est multidimensionnelle donc il y a
des gens qui sont effectivement très
éloigné de l'emploi et pour qui ça va
être très compliqué il y a des gens qui
en sont plus proches ça dépend depuis
combien de temps on aurait ça et de son
histoire de vie personnelle l'expérience
de territoire zérocheurs de longue durée
qui a une expérimentation voulue par le
Parlement avec deux lois qu'ils l'ont
mis en place ça marche aujourd'hui il y
a 53 départements oui c'est quoi la
différence avec ce que vous comprenez
qui va se mettre peut-être en œuvre ça
sous le principe de territoire on part
des gens on les embauche et ils sont
déjà embauchés ils sont embauchés et
après sans conditions sans condition et
après on cherche ensemble c'est quoi le
bon chemin dans quoi ils peuvent être
employés c'est quoi leur capacité dans
l'entreprise au sein de l'entreprise
c'est pour ça que c'est une entreprise à
but d'emploi et c'est tout un défi à
l'équilibre entre l'entreprise qui doit
avoir un certain rendement et
les capacités
dans l'emploi mais avec un
accompagnement ou alors ça c'est l'idéal
pourquoi on fait pas ça à l'échelle du
pays c'est impossible trop cher sans
doute une question budgétaire mais ça
ressemble en revanche à ce que nous
avons fait pour les jeunes le contrat
engagement jeune
300 000 jeunes qui ont retrouvé le
chemin de l'emploi grâce à ces contrats
engagements jeunes 70% des bénéficiaires
de ce contrat d'engagement jeunes ont
trouvé un emploi pérenne un emploi
stable ce qu'il faut voir avec
exactement mais 300000 jeunes qui
étaient vraiment eux très loin de
trouver un emploi le premier emploi et
donc ce dispositif a fonctionné donc
c'est ça le modèle pour les gouvernement
de remettre tout le monde sur le chemin
de l'emploi evidemment on ne peut pas
mettre tout le monde sur la même ligne
de départ en ce qui concerne les
bénéficiaires du RSA la pauvreté est
multifactorielle et un bénéficiaire de
RSA ne ressemble pas à un autre mais
quand on le voit à travers votre
reportage est-ce que dit d'ailleurs le
président du Département c'est qu'il
faut mettre tous les acteurs autour de
la table tous les acteurs locaux et
l'État peut compenser aussi et ça on
parle d'un point de vue budgétaire
Olivier du socle mais ce que le
département met si l'opération
fonctionne l'État peut le compenser à
l'europrait c'est-à-dire que si vous
retrouvez dans votre département du
Travail pour vos bénéficiaires du RSA
prévu parce que pour l'instant ça fait
partie une information
pour l'instant on a juste on a juste le
message politique qui est envoyé
politique et l'application progressive
c'est pas la sanction monsieur le
reconnaît la sanction vous n'êtes pas
favorable j'ai bien compris mais le
dispositif vous êtes plutôt euh
si vous faites pas vos heures d'activité
supplémentaire à la fin il y a plus rien
c'est ça quand même la logique dans la
présentation de cette réforme c'est
adapter c'est-à-dire que quand on prend
l'exemple de la mère de famille
célibataire 3 enfants RSA on va pas lui
proposer un travail à 50 km de chez elle
si elle n'a pas le permis et pas de
solution de garde il faut bien l'avoir
en tête nous ne sommes pas dans du
bénévolat forcé ou du travail forcé
absolument pas j'aurais mis Baudot ce
qu'on sait ce travail c'est 15 heures
d'activité c'est gratuit pour garder son
RSA ou s'est rémunéré ça en devient la
contrepartie mais on peut l'entendre
dans la dans le reportage c'est à dire
que ça ramène les gens ça permet de dire
on va vous aider à faire votre CV on va
vous aider à comment est-ce qu'on
retrouve quand on parle de mobilité le
permis de conduire c'est quelque chose
qui est aujourd'hui coûte cher et ce qui
éloigne des gens de l'emploi notamment
dans des territoires ruraux moi ce que
je trouve étonnant dans cette approche
c'est une approche très politique et
donc très dogmatique et donc qui répond
à une musique qu'on connaît la musique
de l'assistana et c'est ça qui me
dérange un tout petit peu dans dans la
manière dont c'est dans ces dans ces mis
en avant c'est que ça répond à cette à
cette musique de l'assistana
et qui lui parle de tous ceux qui sont
autour d'eux au travail et voit autour
d'eux je cite dans le livre Les kassos
les assister ce qui se lèvent pas le
matin ça c'est une petite musique qu'on
entend et ça c'est plutôt excusez-moi je
termine juste un instant et ça c'est
plutôt quand même une tendance qui va
vers un vote populiste vers un vote
rassemblement national donc lutter
contre ça ça n'est pas forcément dire
pointer du doigt c'est peut-être que ça
manque un peu de clairvoyance
la manière de dire 15 à 20h par mois
n'est pas unique c'est pas tout à fait
de dire on va leur proposer des ateliers
vous voyez enfin le narratif le message
est pas le même et donc la réception
n'est pas du tout la même parce que
peut-être sur François Ruffin parce que
c'est lui qui constate ça hein
contre le RSA conditionné évidemment
parce que au fond effectivement il y a
cette petite musique je parlais de bouc
émissaire d'assistanat en fait ce que
vous essayez de dire au classement
moyenne que vous plongez de plus en plus
en difficulté puisque les salaires réels
ont diminué de 3% l'année dernière donc
plutôt évidemment nous qu'est-ce qu'on
pointe on poin les Ultra riches les
milliardaires se comptent de plus en
plus d'argent et qui captent la majorité
de la croissance et vous vous dites NON
NON regardez les chômeurs là c'est eux
là et c'est ça le problème là si c'est
ce que et je vais vous dire le problème
je vais vous citer Martin hirs qui est
quand même pas le plus révolutionnaire
de gauche des hommes politiques qu'on
connaît au commissaire à la solidarité
et à la pêche il dit le problème c'est
que ça va ça va transformer tous ces
bénéficiaires du RSA en une main
d'oeuvre sans droit sans droit parce que
vous le savez mais c'est pas vrai
je ne vous ai pas coupé
[Musique]
j'ai du mal à les retenir pour vous y
répondre
c'est pas un travail c'est de la
formation payer un permis de conduire
c'est pas un travail forcé est-ce qu'on
est d'accord avec ça si donc une
activité
est-ce que vous reconnaissez que ça va
dans le bon sens attendez le problème
n'est pas là le problème vous pouvez
répondre à la question là ça va dans le
bon sens quand même accompagnement est
une bonne une bonne chose mais il n'y a
pas mais vous n'y mettez pas les moyens
le problème le problème vous me laissez
parler à la fin le problème c'est la
sanction c'est-à-dire que vous dites aux
gens attention si vous ne si vous ne
répondez pas à l'appel comme vous dites
si vous ne travaillez pas quasi
gratuitement à 607 euros sans droit
qu'est-ce que vous proposez vous serez
vous aurez Aurélie trouver alors je vais
vous dire nous s'il n'y a pas de
sanction que vous dites oui à la
campagne
je peux vous répondre s'il va bien me
laisser parler donc nous d'abord c'est
pourquoi j'ai commencé par la
philosophie parce que je dis nous disons
la République c'était droit une aliéna
donc nous on est pour une garantie
d'autonomie voilà parce que le fait de
vivre dignement avec le minimum pour
vivre il n'y a pas de conditions
garantie d'autonomie
ou pas en plus du ça là je dis garantie
d'autonomie pour tous ceux qui n'ont pas
qui n'arrivent pas à se revenus là un
revenu minimum garanti le cas
aujourd'hui non de 1100 euros voilà
parce que pour nous le seul de pauvreté
c'est ce qui permet aujourd'hui de vivre
dignement sans condition ça c'est la
première chose deuxièmement des moyens
d'accompagnement bien supérieurs bien
supérieur mis sur la table troisièmement
une toute autre logique qui est vrai
véritablement de créer de l'emploi par
la demande et aujourd'hui on a un vrai
problème c'est que les entreprises le
disent le problème aujourd'hui pour
créer de l'emploi c'est le carnet de
commandes mais seulement vous êtes
enfermé vous dans une logique d'offres
le problème c'est la demande populaire
donc derrière c'est il faut des
consommateurs qui consomment des
entreprises en ce moment il faut vous
allez te voir dans le Finistère toutes
les banderoles
regardez il y a du boulot
les enquêtes
du ministère du Travail
le problème
alors notamment des travailleurs voilà
et augmenter les impôts
ce qui est très important dans ce débat
c'est qui coûte très cher on entend les
contre-propositions des insoumis c'est
la même chose que côté gouvernement ça
se chiffre en milliards j'ai regardé
2000 euros par allocataire c'est ce que
dit Antoine Dulin président de la
commission d'insertion des jeunes si on
fait cette réforme 2000 euros par un
locataire du RSA mais c'était quelque
chose qui n'arrivera pas en fait
il n'y a pas les moyens
imaginez ce que ça coûterait à la
société quand les gens quand les
familles avaient enfant se retrouveront
sans RS à couper
quand on se retrouve en logements sans
pouvoir payer leur loyer ça va coûter
énormément d'argent et c'est le principe
de le BE de l'entreprise à but d'emploi
dans les territoires zéro chômeurs c'est
que l'argent
investit socialement réinvestit dans
l'entreprise pour l'aider à embaucher
les gens et là et ce qui manque et
produit par le travail des gens et en
fait il faut quand on parle de coup il
faut imaginer le coût humain passer
absolument terrible aujourd'hui quand
nous on voit des gens qui sont sans
recours parce que il y a des personnes
qui ont tellement peur du RSA tellement
peur du contrôle qu'aujourd'hui ils
disent non non moi je vais pas demander
le RSA et donc aujourd'hui 34% des gens
qui sont sans RSA sans recours et qui
aurait droit et donc nous notre crainte
et l'ambiguïté c'est qu'avec cette
réforme et la peur qu'elle véhicule
c'est que les gens nous disent non non
il y a trop de contrôle j'y vais pas
parce que la vie des gens très pauvres
et en permanence soumis au contrôle
aujourd'hui au RSA il est possible pour
les travailleurs sociaux de vérifier ce
qu'il y a sur le compte en banque des
gens
donc c'est quand même un contrôle
extrêmement fort même s'ils ne sont pas
sous tutelles donc il y a vraiment des
peurs qui sont véculés et fois les
entendre il faut les les
comprendre et c'est une des choses qui
nous manque c'est que cette réforme et
de manière générale l'action sociale n'a
pas été pensée avec les bénéficiaires et
là on éviterait un certain nombre
d'écueils si tout ça était bâti avec les
bénéficiaires et non pas comme une vue
d'en haut on va mettre tout le monde au
travail et c'est magique le remède
serait pire colmal vous allez créer du
non recours les gens vont ressentir
menacés par les sanctions et les
contrôles il y a déjà beaucoup de non
recours au RSA et pourquoi ne pas
d'abord construire avec les principaux
concernés cette mesure tout à l'heure
vous vous demandiez pourquoi faire cette
réforme dans le timing qui est le nôtre
je crois que si vous avez bien lu le
programme d'Emmanuel Macron il n'y a pas
que la réforme de retraite il n'y a pas
que la réforme du RSA et pour vous
répondre et pour ajouter de l'eau à
votre moulin il y a la solidarité à la
source ça c'est une révolution dans
l'aide sociale de la distribution de
l'étiquette
[Musique]
même pourquoi pas le privé avec les
entreprises qui pourraient venir à un
moment donné après une formation après
un accompagnement ou de l'insertion d'un
bénéficiaire de RSA promettre une
embauche et ben vous financez finalement
cette réforme par un partenariat
tranquille
sans en détailler les contours parce que
le projet doit se présenter dans
quelques semaines a dit que ça serait
une application progressive de cette
réforme ces expérimentations ne sont pas
là pour être dans le gadget elles sont
là pour voir si les choses peuvent
fonctionner avec la différation la
différenciation territoriale à laquelle
nous sommes attachés et le président du
département du Loiret je crois le disait
on ne fait pas la même chose dans le
Loiret comme on les ferait dans les
Pyrénées-Orientales où en
Seine-Saint-Denis et donc il faut
prendre les choses de manière je crois
totalement dépassionnés et moi j'appelle
y compris les insoumis à aider à ce que
en France demain il n'y ait plus de
bénéficiaires du RSA mais que chacun
puisse vivre dignement de son travail ça
a pas l'air d'être le sentiment que vous
donnez dans le débat qui est le nôtre
mais je vois que y compris dans la nups
certains
pourrait essayer au moins d'enrichir ce
genre de texte pourquoi pas François
vous n'y croyez pas du tout
politiquement Jean-Rémy Baudot ça passe
et de droite et de gauche on peut
chercher des deux côtés sur un texte
pareil ça clique de droite la droite
vous pensez parce que déjà on lit ça
n'est pas suffisant cet accompagnement
c'était plutôt des sanctions qui étaient
recherchées
on peut avoir une partie de la droite je
ça m'étonnerait qu'il y ait une partie
de la gauche justement parce qu'on est
dans cette dans ce dans cette impossible
dialogue sur il y a d'un côté la droite
qui dit attention il faut aller chercher
les assister et de l'autre la gauche qui
dit non surtout on touche pas au plus
précaire c'est de la stigmatisation etc
d'ailleurs en omettant parfois aussi les
effets de seuil qui sont liés au RSA
avec toutes les toutes les entre
guillemets tout ce qui va autour du RSA
avec les APL la gratuité dans certains
départements donc en fait le coup
parfois de la reprise de l'emploi est
extrêmement élevé pour certains
bénéficiaires parce que je dis pas
qu'ils vivent bien bien évidemment c'est
absolument pas mon propos mais il y a
parfois la limite et la limite entre le
quelqu'un qui gagnera un SMIC à temps
partiel et quelqu'un qui touche un RSA à
temps plein ne peut être parfois assez
fine donc c'est en tout cas juste un
débat à voir et peut-être en fait
l'écueil actuel c'est qu'on a repose pas
la question du RSA et qu'on applique un
message qui est il faut de la formation
il faut des contrôles et que forcément
ça tourne plutôt à droite une question à
nos invités peut-être avec ce débat qui
s'achève non je crois qu'il faut aller
vers ce genre de débat avec son
démagogie avec pragmatisme voilà et
effectivement connaître déjà le le plan
du gouvernement le projet éventuellement
qu'ils ont qu'ils ont à l'esprit je vais
vous donner le mot de la fin pour ATD
Quart Monde je trouve que ce qui est
important c'est de sortir des idées
fausses des fausses que les gens ne
veulent pas travailler que les gens RSA
ne veulent pas travailler qu'ils sont
des finances c'est faux les gens et on a
plein les gens veulent retourner faire
une vie descente et une vie descente
c'est pas le RSA à 600 7 euros
encore une fois quand on a enlevé en
dessous c'est même c'est largement en
dessous du seuil de grande pauvreté même
mais vous êtes prêts à travailler avec
les pouvoirs publics pour essayer de
construire ou co-construire quelque
chose nous on a des Carmaux on en est ni
de droite ni de gauche notre point de
travail c'est qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
pour les personnes qui ont la vie la
plus difficile est-ce qu'on va s'assurer
que personne ne va être abandonné sur le
bord du chemin est-ce que vraiment les
gens qui sont en non recours au RSA
aujourd'hui vont pouvoir s'en sortir et
à gagner des sécurités est-ce que les
gens qui sont RSA aujourd'hui vont pas
se retrouver dans une situation pire que
celle dans laquelle ils sont encore
beaucoup beaucoup de travail pour
l'instant avec toutes les forces qui
veulent toutes les forces il faut une
volonté politique pour éradiquer la
pauvreté on verra si elle est au grand
désert elle doit être de tout bord on va
s'arrêter là merci beaucoup on va en
reparler forcément ces début juin c'est
bien ça la réforme France travail dans
laquelle cette réforme RSA sera
introduite on aura l'occasion d'y
revenir en longueur merci à vous merci
d'être venu sur LCB pour se débat vous
restez avec moi rue des reichstad dans
une dizaine de minutes les parties pris
de nos affranchis ce soir la féministe
Léa chamboncel pousse un cri d'alarme
sur la pénurie de pilule pilule abortive
lutte c'est le mot de la semaine de
notre sémiologue Mariette darrigan et
puis Bourbon Express Marco pommier va
nous raconter que des députés de tout
bord font cause commune sur les déserts
médicaux mais d'abord on va se plonger
dans ce petit livre passionnant je le
disais à la fois personnel et assez
effrayant quand on lit et bien les
attaques les attaques en meute numérique
que vous avez subi mais pas seulement
vous et vos équipes de conspiration
watch c'est un site qui démontre qui
analyse et qui combat toutes les
théories du complot on en parle juste
après l'invitation d'Elsa mon Agava vous
allez le voir on a encore quelques
raisons d'espérer
[Musique]
si on vous invite Rudy Reichstadt c'est
parce que vous étudiez les phénomènes
conspirationnistes depuis 15 ans vous
décortiquez les théories du complot
assassinat de Kennedy 11 septembre
covid-19 vous rétablissez les faits rue
dirait stade vous êtes politologue
fondateur du site conspiration watch en
2019 vous publiez l'opium des imbéciles
et aujourd'hui au cœur du complot on ne
croit pas du tout que le complotisme se
soit un problème de déficience
intellectuel c'est pas vrai c'est des
gens très intelligents qui versent et
qui se vôtre dans le complotisme ce que
je veux dire c'est que c'est avant tout
un problème de fragilité éventuellement
fragilité psychologique et de faiblesse
exactement de paresse intellectuelle
c'est différent on peut être très
intelligent et ne part se servir de son
cerveau dans votre livre vous citez la
loi de Brandolini selon laquelle
l'énergie dépensait pour réfuter les
fausses informations
et bien supérieur à celle qu'il faut
pour les propager mais vous ruir echtad
ce n'est pas seulement votre énergie que
vous dépensez sur les réseaux sociaux
vous êtes devenus une cible pour ce que
vous combattez menace de mort
insultantisémite accusation de
pédocriminalité alors sale juif tu n'as
toujours pas fermé ton ignoble site
[Musique]
tu sais qu'un jour tu risques d'être
tondu
les racailles de ton espèce pervers
pédophile sache que le moment venu on va
vous traquer vous dégager très
prochainement
pourtant vous ne baissez pas les bras
alors Rudy reichstad quand vous voyez
que 35% des Français croient au théories
du complot
n'avez-vous pas le sentiment que le
combat est perdu
on vous la poser souvent cette question
quel est votre réponse ma réponse c'est
que les batailles qu'on ne mène pas on
est sur de les perdre donc non moi si je
le croyais si je croyais que mon action
celle qu'on a à la conspiration watch
était absolument inutile effectivement
on se lèverait pas le matin et on fera
autre chose non je crois qu'il est utile
ne serait-ce que parce que oui on
suscite énormément de violences de
virulence au-delà de la critique c'est
vraiment des attaques très très ignobles
et en même temps on reçoit aussi
beaucoup de messages d'encouragement de
soutien de gens qui me disent
heureusement que vous êtes là continuez
alors ce qui est facilement dans ce
livre et c'est aussi assez effrayant
c'est que tout ce que vous avez subi
tous ces torrents debout vous ont placé
finalement vous et vos compagnons
d'infortune de conspiraci watch au
centre de votre objet d'étude finalement
vous êtes au poste d'observation du
complotisme et vous êtes devenu votre
propre laboratoire de recherche est-ce
que vous auriez pu imaginer ça
écoutez je l'ai pressenti assez tôt
parce que les comment dire les attaques
sont arrivés très tôt mais des attaques
complotistes c'est-à-dire que le fait
d'analyser sous un angle critique le
complotisme fait qu'on devient soi-même
un objet cristallisation de théories du
complot en gros on nous accuse d'être
nous-mêmes des comploteurs ou des
complices des comploteurs d'être
nous-mêmes manipulés ou très conscients
de ça etc donc nous on est bien placé
moi les gens avec qui je travaille ceux
qui luttent ou qui critiquent les
théories du complot pas seulement
conspiration d'ailleurs on est bien
placé pour savoir que les complots dont
on nous accuse sont faux on sait qu'on
travaille pas pour des lobbies obscures
ou la CIA etc donc je trouvais que
c'était intéressant de le raconter comme
ça de manière très subjective à la
première personne parce que pour
l'instant ça n'est pas encore été fait
on va y revenir dans le détail sur ces
différentes attaques d'abord les menaces
de mort elles arrivent quasiment tout de
suite deux 2018 2008 pardon 2010 2010
après la création du site menace de mort
caractérisée pour laquelle j'ai porté
plainte et puis ensuite ça a été un long
chapelet de d'intimidation de d'injures
etc mais notamment de menaces alors sous
la forme de même vous savez c'est-à-dire
des images de guillotine de potence
on nous met enfin il faut imaginer on
met notre photo derrière un hublot de
chambre à gaz par exemple
et effectivement c'est très violent il
faut garder la tête froide se dire que
c'est la preuve que on a mis le doigt là
où ça faisait mal sinon on susciterait
pas une telle une telle virulence mais
c'est vrai que c'est pénible à vivre
plus que ça quand même ce qui est ce qui
frappe c'est que vous cristallisez une
détestation immonde il y a beaucoup de
choses il y a les soraliens il y a les
proches de Dieudonné qui vous ciblent on
vous soupçonne d'être financé par George
Soros par Bill Gates par une puissance
étrangère on retrouve l'idée que vous
seriez soit un agent du maussade soit
que vous dirigeriez une officine
sioniste il y a un fil rouge quand même
me semble
ça revient beaucoup parce que d'abord il
faut le dire c'est une idéologie pour
laquelle le complotisme le
conspirationnisme a eu sans doute un
rôle équivalent ou plus grave encore que
le racisme c'est-à-dire que
fondamentalement l'antisémitisme c'est
l'accusation de complot Juifs alors donc
c'est inextricablement lié à l'histoire
anti mais puis il y a tout un matériel
symbolique en circulation un
dissolublement complotiste et antisémite
qui est prête à l'emploi sur internet
aujourd'hui et qui peut être réactivé
voilà dans ce genre de circonstances
alors les bureaux du site sont attaqués
par un groupe de complotistes radicalisé
manifesté devant ça quand même ça
devient c'est plus virtuel donc ça
devient physique vous êtes devenu un
aimant à fake news c'est votre
expression support de fantasmes
complotiste le plus immonde vous
raconter ce sont les accusations de
pédocriminalité dans le siège du délire
des curane américain vous prenez des
coups et vous dites
les risques du métier en revanche pour
certains de vos proches ça n'est pas
leur métier et cette année jusqu'à vos
proches jusqu'à votre compagne
sur les réseaux sociaux dont la photo
maintenant on se retrouve dans des
vidéos complotistes expliquant toutes
choses d'ailleurs le prétend toutes
sortes de de choses alors que par
ailleurs elle a tout à fait étrangère à
tout ce que je fais et là c'est à la
fois inquiétant et ça nous met très en
colère donc on porte plein dans ces
cas-là et puis on attend que la justice
passe en ayant bien conscience que le
tribunal populaire des réseaux sociaux
n'est pas la justice c'est la justice
dans sa forme archétx et lynchage en
République on est en droit d'attendre un
peu mieux que ça et vous avez fait le
choix de les citer ces messages et de ne
pas anonymiser leur hauteur pourquoi
pourquoi parce que je crois que les gens
sont responsables de leurs actes de
leurs paroles et que ils le font soit
sous pseudonyme soit sur leur nom mais à
ce moment là ils en sont comptables
alors ils sont responsables est-ce qu'on
peut parler avec eux franchement est-ce
qu'on peut leur répondre est-ce qu'ils
sont récupérables alors de quoi on parle
est-ce qu'on parle des complotistes des
gens qui sont intoxiqués par ces
choses-là et qui sont pas dans une
certitude fanatique oui je crois que il
faut occuper le terrain pour leur parler
pour les attraper pour qu'ils puissent
réfléchir et éventuellement douter de
leur propre doute et douter des théories
du complot après je crois qu'on a chez
les complotistes les plus convaincus des
gens qui sont comparables à des
supporters d'une équipe de foot même à
des hooligans pour qui la question du
vrai et du faux est totalement
secondaire c'est pas leur problème vous
pouvez leur montrer que il relaie des
mensonges ça n'aura aucun effet donc eux
sont assez largement irrécupérables puis
vous avez les meneurs les leaders
d'opinion les cyniques les influenceurs
qui eux font ça parce qu'ils en font un
vrai business politique une entreprise
politique d'ailleurs fabriquent des fake
news en connaissance de cause il y en a
beaucoup mais vous utilisez ce terme
d'imbécile qui peut surprendre ils sont
plus bêtes que les autres les ai
récupérables
mon premier lit s'appelait l'opium des
imbéciles qui était une référence
explicite à un mot de Auguste bubble qui
parlait de l'antisémitisme justement
comme du socialisme des imbéciles en
substance il disait ça a rien de faire
le détour par l'antisémitisme pour être
anti capitaliste en gros pour critiquer
pour critiquer le système capitaliste et
faire avancer la cause du socialisme
bien là je crois que on est dans la même
situation pour critiquer le système on
n'a pas besoin de faire ce détour qui
peut être un chemin de perdition
d'ailleurs par la théorie du complot
parce que la théorie du complot elle a
partie liée aujourd'hui et à travers
l'histoire avec des discours de
stigmatisation avec la logique du bouc
émissaire et avec évidemment le racisme
antimitisme et la violence alors c'est
très intéressant on a évoqué cette loi
de Brandolini il y a cette mécanique de
l'inversion accusatoire c'est un peu un
monstre le complotisme nihydra plusieurs
tests vous en coupez une et il en
repousse beaucoup d'autres
dans ce combat les médias et les
politiques ont une responsabilité
absolument essentielle c'est un enjeu
vital pour la démocratie alors il y a
beaucoup de choses sur les médias vont
parler du site France soit on va pas y
revenir aujourd'hui aux mains d'un
certain Xavier Azalbert antivax il y a
aussi des médias mainstream beaucoup
plus puissants et qui véhiculent des
fake news vous diriez par exemple que le
plateau de Cyril Hanouna accueille
régulièrement des invités qui débattent
de rumeurs sans fondement est-ce qu'il
faut qu'il arrête est-ce que vous lui
dites attention
je crois que c'est une émission qui
s'inscrit dans un dispositif de
blanchiment si vous voulez de d'acteurs
de la complot sphère dans le sens où les
gens qui passent par cette émission
capitalisant suite la légitimité
cathodique qu'ils ont acquises dans
l'émission de Cyril Hanouna sur le web
en retour et donc on va sortir de leur
confidentialité des gens qui ne
représentent que même mais qui ont un
certain aplomb une certaine Goua et quoi
et qui vont soutenir des thèses
complètement farfelues complètement
fantaisistes devant des millions de
personnes toutes génération confondues
parce que c'est une émission très suivie
que celle de dont on parle sur sur C8
donc oui il y a une responsabilité de ce
genre de médias-là comme il y en a de
médias dit alternatifs de réinfosphère
sur le web qui sont très franchement un
tropisme très marqué à l'extrême droite
il faut quand même le dire on parle de
médias comme Radio Courtoisie TV liberté
Sud Radio dont l'émission phares et
animée par André Bercoff et qui fait
circuler toutes ces figures d'influence
complotistes et les politiques alors on
sort d'un débat hier à l'Assemblée
nationale sur la réintégration des des
soignants non vaccinés et dans
l'hémicycle vous avez certains députés
pour ne pas le citer Nicolas
Dupont-Aignan qui explique clairement
que pour lui le vaccin est un surcroît
de mortalité ce qui fait dire au
ministre de la santé que le complotisme
sur la science dans ce débat qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire il y a une double
responsabilité quand on est élu et
pourtant ça existe une exigence de
comment dire d'exemplarité également
donc c'est inquiétant lorsqu'on a un élu
qui a une carrière dans les rues
nationales comme celle de Nicolas
Dupont-Aignan de le voir jouer avec ce
genre de thématique ou avec l'idée que
les élections seraient pas fiables etc
on l'a entendu aussi dire ça l'année
dernière Nicolas Dupont-Aignan il a pris
ce créneau là depuis plusieurs années
maintenant
l'antivax relayer les inquiétudes et
au-delà une forme d'hystérie
anti-accination et de et de de défiance
à l'égard du vaccin alors que c'est
aujourd'hui le médicament qui nous a
sorti d'une pandémie mondiale quand même
dernière question très rapidement
Elon Musk patron de twitter est-il un
ennemi de la vérité de la démocratie on
enlevant par exemple les certifications
qui authentifient les comptes
gratuitement
système de certification payant en fait
en introduisant une logique sansitaire
dans l'accès à liberté d'expression à la
visibilité sur Twitter là on est six
mois après sa prise de contrôle de la
plateforme on peut en tirer un premier
bilan et pour le moment on peut dire
qu'il est très inquiétant ce sont des
dizaines de milliers de comptes qui
avaient été des plateformées et pas pour
de mauvaises raisons qu'on de
désinformation qui sont revenus et qui
sont aujourd'hui plus visibles que
jamais et ça nourrit chez eux une forme
de désinhibition dans la parole et y
compris la parole violente merci
beaucoup on vous réinvitera parce
qu'avec l'intelligence artificielle qui
arrive qui permet plus de distinguer le
vrai du faux il y a encore un chantier
titanesque pour les politiques devant
merci infiniment au cœur du complot
c'est à dire c'est grâce à vous restez
avec moi parce que c'est l'heure
d'accueillir bien sûr nos affranchis
pour leur parti pris ils vont vous faire
réagir c'est à eux tout de suite
et bienvenue Mario Darry grand merci
d'être avec nous ces myologues à titre
de l'émission pour son mot de la semaine
c'est luth aujourd'hui et puis les
hambelles bonsoir on va parler de la
pilule abortive et de la pénurie plus
qu'inquiétante pour pour les femmes dans
notre pays mais on commence comme chaque
soir par Bourbon Express l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée nous est racontée ce
soir par Marco pommier bonsoir Marco
bonsoir Myriam ce soir je vous raconte
l'histoire du Tour de France alors pas
celui qui va se dérouler en juillet on
parle pas de cyclisme on parle du tour
de France des déserts médicaux lancé par
une quarantaine de députés
issus de 9 groupes parlementaires de la
France insoumise aux républicains en
passant par la majorité il défendent une
proposition de loi soutenue par plus de
200 parlementaires pour lutter contre la
pénurie de généraliste ou de
spécialistes en France nous on a assisté
à la 11e étape de ce Tour la onzième
réunion publique c'était mercredi soir à
Châteaudun une centaine de personnes
dans la salle et sur scène 4 députés
pour une alliance improbable Philippe
Vigier du MoDem nous étions dans sa
circonscription Christophe Marion de
renaissance le socialiste Guillaume Garo
mais aussi l'insoumis Adrien cloué
écoutez-le vous êtes député de la France
insoumise et vous faites des réunions
publiques au 4 coins du pays avec des
députés de la majorité vous le vivez
bien ah bah oui je le vis bien
maintenant on est d'accord vous voyez ce
qui se passe ici c'est l'exemple c'est
la matérialisation du fait que au
Parlement on peut organiser la marge du
pays et que souvent les obstacles c'est
du côté de l'exécutif du côté du
gouvernement et que lorsqu'on tord pas
le bras au député lorsqu'on ne nous
permet de voter de délibérer d'examiner
un texte tranquillement et surtout de le
rédiger eux-mêmes et bien il y a des
majorités possibles qui existent
alors elle contient quoi cette
proposition de loi et bien la
proposition phare c'est de réguler
l'installation des médecins en fonction
des besoins sur les territoires ce sont
les agences de santé en fait qui
délivreraient l'autorisation
d'installation en clair dans les déserts
médicaux les professionnels de santé
seraient les bienvenus en revanche hors
des airs médicales pas d'installation
sauf si c'est pour remplacer un départ à
la retraite la mesure s'appliquerait au
généraliste aux spécialistes et
chirurgiens dentistes écoutez est-ce que
vous ne pensez pas que la régulation
peut avoir un impact sur l'attractivité
de ces métiers alors c'est la menace que
peut faire peser les internes notamment
moi j'y crois pas parce qu'au fond quand
ce lance dans un dans des études
médicales c'est quand même
essentiellement et avant tout pour aider
d'autant qu'aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup
de professions médicales qui sont
régulées il y a finalement que dans la
médecine libérale est dans la médecine
générale qu'on n'a pas cette question de
la régulation voilà remettre en cause la
liberté d'installation des médecins si
ça passe ça va susciter une levée de
bouclier absolument dingue ça parce
qu'en dit il y a quand même un hic dans
l'histoire Myriam parce que ce texte il
n'est même pas inscrit dans le
calendrier parlementaire et oui une
pétition a donc été lancée plus de 44000
signatures pour le moment vous le voyez
mais le gouvernement en fait il est
défavorable à ce texte transpartisant il
mise plutôt sur un autre texte soutenu
par le reste de la majorité celui de
Frédéric Valtou député du groupe horizon
lui dit vouloir faire confiance aux
professionnels de santé en partant des
territoires pour régler les problèmes
mais pas question de régulation
aujourd'hui notre problème principal le
premier problème c'est le manque de
soignants ce serait à l'heure de faire
croire aux Français qu'en votant
simplement la régulation d'un
installation du jour au lendemain des
territoires qui se battent les flancs
pour avoir des médecins depuis des
années en aurait comme par miracle parce
que de toute façon le sujet n'est pas là
le sujet c'est que c'est on n'a pas
assez de professionnels à répartir
exactement alors contrairement au texte
trans partisan le texte de Frédéric
valtoul lui sera débattu à l'Assemblée
la semaine du 12 juin il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui 8 millions de Français
vivent dans un désert médical on suivra
ça on verra comment ça débouche
politiquement Léa vous vouliez revenir
sur le manque cruel de pilule abortives
en France j'ai bien dit presque avec la
chronique de Bourbon Express
effectivement c'est grâce à un hashtag
lancé sur Twitter par la militante
maryco qui chanbel que la question de la
pénurie des pilules abortives a commencé
à avoir la visibilité sur les réseaux
sociaux en parallèle des parlementaires
se sont mobilisés pour interpeller les
gouvernements le gouvernement et
plusieurs questions écrites ont été
déposées par des députés de l'opposition
comme de la majorité dans la foulée un
collectif d'associations a lancé le 27
avril une pétition afin de demander au
gouvernement d'agir face à un état
d'urgence sanitaire en matière divergé
alors comment expliquer cette pénurie
alors il s'agit plus précisément d'une
pénurie misoprostol qui remonte
maintenant à plusieurs semaines le
misoprostol est en fait une molécule qui
est nécessaire aux IVG médicamenteuses
et qui est produite de manière exclusive
par le laboratoire nordique Pharma et
depuis 2020 déjà le Haut Conseil à
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
alerte sur ses risques de pénuries en
soulignant notamment le rôle que
pourrait jouer les anti IVG dans les
décisions stratégiques de certaines
entreprises pharmaceutiques et ont le
sait les entiers végés donc celles et
ceux qui sont contre le droit à
l'avortement ont des moyens assez
importants et une influence considérable
tant et si bien qu'ils ont déjà réussi
dans plusieurs pays à faire en sorte de
cesser la commercialisation de la pilule
abortive alors concrètement concret va
se passer il y aura des conséquences
pour les femmes pour les personnes qui
souhaitent avorter puisque dans
plusieurs régions de France il n'y a
plus on a plus accès aux pilule
abordives dans un pays où quand même 76%
des IVG sont réalisés par voie
médicamenteux ces situations est quand
même assez inquiétante et ça remet
concrètement l'accès à ce droit
fondamental pour de nombreuses personnes
cette question a aussi pour impact de
faire en sorte de créer en fait de
l'anxiété et de l'incertitude pour les
personnes qui souhaiteraient avorter et
enfin dans un communiqué de presse qui a
été publié le 29 avril par le planning
familial le collectif avortement en
Europe les femmes décident et
l'Observatoire de la transparence dans
le médicament ces associations demandent
à l'État de prendre des mesures afin
comme afin de faire en sorte que les
pilules abordives soient finalement
accessibles comme la production de
misoprostol au niveau national et
européen et où l'importation de
générique et le gouvernement qu'est-ce
qui fait alors le gouvernement ne fait
pas grand chose puisque encore hier des
députés écolos ont interpellé le
ministre de la Santé à travers un
courrier en lui demandant d'agir
aujourd'hui aucune réponse que ce soit
du côté du ministère de la santé ou du
côté du ministère des Droits des Femmes
et donc ce soir moi j'ai une question à
poser au gouvernement c'est-à-dire
qu'est-ce que vous entendez vraiment
faire pour répondre à ces situations qui
devient de plus en plus urgentes mais
voilà l'appel est lancé à François Brown
le ministre de la Santé et de vous
répondra je l'espère on n'a pas le temps
de vous faire réagir mais on votre
rencontre voilà que les entiers végés
qui sont bien présents aussi sur les
réseaux sociaux s'infiltre dans chaque
débat et dans nos faiblesses en
l'occurrence cette pénurie Mariette
lutte cette semaine pourquoi ce mot
parce qu'on a entendu beaucoup
d'expressions après la promulgation de
la réforme sur les retraites on continue
lutte on ne tourne pas la page et puis
il y a bien sûr la lutte contre les fake
news il y a la lutte contre l'inflation
bref ce vieux vieux mot est très à la
mode
violent c'est la lutte gréco-romaine
donc ça nous rajeunit pas ça nous amène
dans l'Antiquité avec une vision si vous
voulez du choc de l'affrontement très
physique très athlétique donc c'est un
côté gladiateur très Marvel ça a été
repris dans des séries télé ou bien dans
des films c'est très spectaculaire la
lutte bien sûr il y a une violence
physique dans ce mot de lutte exactement
à l'ancienne ça pose la question de la
violence physique et c'est ça qui fait
que je pense il faut s'intéresser la
circulation du mot parce qu'elle il met
ce mot de la violence dans l'air
aujourd'hui on voit bien alors hypothèse
peut-être que c'est parce que la lutte
des classes concept symbolique un
concept abstrait canaliser quelque chose
de cette violence mais aujourd'hui du
tout quelque chose que l'on entend l'une
des classes et donc c'est comme si
c'était cette idée c'était dissoute dans
autre chose bon qui s'appelle le
populisme qui est toujours un
affrontement un duel de de grands voilà
de grandes forces athlétiques très très
affronté si vous voulez dans un choc on
dit souvent aussi brutal on a ça
aujourd'hui dans notre dans notre
panorama il faudrait le changer ce mot
là où alors il y a des chercheurs en
sciences sociales aujourd'hui qui ont
théorisé ce mot en le prenant en grec
parce qu'en grec c'était la Gonne et
donc
antagonisme si vous voulez et puis
agonie ça c'est vraiment quand on va aux
extrêmes et alors ce que c'est ces
personnes là disent aujourd'hui c'est la
démocratie et des facto agonistiques
puisqu'elle est sur l'affrontement alors
ça se discute beaucoup personnellement
je trouve que c'est l'expression est
très ronflante que c'est faussements
savants et que ça n'empêche pas le
recyclage en quelque sorte de la vieille
lutte finale révolutionnaire est quand
même assez souvent sanguinaire donc je
suis pas très favorable à vous vouliez
citer je crois l'anthropologue des
années 50 Roger cailliois exactement je
pense que c'est plutôt ça qui est
intéressant alors c'était la théorie des
jeux chez kaiwa et la lutte faisait
partie des quatre grands jeux je cite
pas les trois autres mais ce qui est à
retenir et surtout que notre société est
devenue très ludique ce qui est à
retenir c'est en si vous voulez c'est
que la lutte doit rester un jeu elle
doit rester un spectacle c'est pour de
faux pour de beau parce que ça donne un
beau spectacle athlétique c'est très
spectaculaire très élégienique si on
veut ou tiktokables mais pas dans le
passage dans le vrai voilà et ça c'est
une idée clé pour notre démocratie qui
est fondée au contraire sur le on en
vient pas aux mains alors juste pour
terminer ma Myriam c'est que l'année
prochaine nous allons avoir les JO et
dans les JO il y a la lutte
gréco-romaine comme la plus vieille des
disciplines et qu'elle aura lieu sous le
Grand Palais éphémère c'est quand même
incroyable il sera rebaptisé Arena du
Champ de Mars et ben j'espère que vous
aurez des places pour nous on verra ça
merci c'était passionnant les mots
évidemment des complotistes
merci beaucoup pour ce mot de la semaine
et Merci à VOUS Léa Marco à la semaine
prochaine lisez au coeur du complot chez
Grasset c'est signé rue des Rastadt
aussi personnel qu'effrayant mais avec
une petite dose quand même de
d'optimisme voilà c'est le weekend
profitez bien très belle soirée et à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]